April is Autism Awareness Month Mary
Jane beliesza shares how Southern Nevada
is Raising Awareness on autism in
minority communities and the help
available
Dr Jerry who takes pride in being a dad
he knows the challenges when it comes to
raising kids and the bigger challenge
when a child is on the Spectrum well
being a minority myself and I have three
boys my youngest he was a preemie baby
and so he had issues a spectrum autism
spectrum disorder and you know in the
past without the education or the
resources or the treatment options
available you know it's even harder a
new CDC report finds one in 36 children
have been identified with an autism
spectrum disorder in the United States
for the first time the percentage of
Asian Black and Hispanic children
diagnosed was higher than white children
Denisha Mingo owner of Mingo Health
Solutions says autism education is the
first step the behaviors that children
on the Spectrum May exhibit are
misinterpreted as maybe being
disobedient or aggressive or dramatic
just because that people do not know
Mingo says early intervention is the
biggest key in managing autism and is
pushing for easier access as some
families may not have Affordable Health
Care going to someone and being able to
pay for that diagnosis in order to even
get into treatment becomes another
barrier and because they're just not
enough providers in general and then not
enough minority providers who where
families can feel a sense of safety and
Trust Doctor Who Says managing autism is
now much easier for their family with
the proper Health Care nutrition and
sleep routine and this is my child right
now he's in gymnastics you know he's in
the school I have friends in sleepovers
and things like that I mean that's what
we want and I think that because I
intervened so early I did mild
functional therapy I expanded his Airway
did those things it's just really I know
what parent wouldn't want to do anything
and everything for their child